[Musica]
[Applauso]
laika movie
quando ho letto il titolo di questo
evento per la prima volta ho pensato a
quante volte utilizziamo l'espressione è
come un film per descrivere certi
accadimenti delle nostre vite ad esempio
lo utilizziamo per descrivere dei fatti
fuori del nostro ordinario tipo ieri
sera ero al mare ho visto un tramonto
bellissimo con le barche all'orizzonte
il cielo colori pazzeschi sembrava di
essere in un film oppure ancora possiamo
usarlo per descrivere situazioni più
assurde fuori dall'ordinario tipo
qualche tempo fa ero con marcello in
macchina stava guidando prende una curva
o ora scende per cambiare la ruota in
quel momento passa un uccello splash
gliela fa tutta in testa sembrava di
essere in un film
insomma immagino che ognuno di noi abbia
utilizzato questa frase almeno una volta
nella vita
nel mio caso specifico il mio lavoro di
racconta storie su youtube mi ha portato
spesso all'interno di queste di queste
scene da film ad esempio quando
conosciuto flaminio qui pensavo di
essere sul set di un film ambientato nel
medioevo in cui il protagonista indossa
un bellissimo costume di scena
oppure ancora quando ho conosciuto
rossella
qui pensavo di essere in un set di un
film post apocalittico perché rossella è
l'unica abitante del borgo abbandonato
di pentidattilo qui ho pensato che
questo film dovesse avere veramente un
budget importante perché la scenografia
e la tanta roba oppure ancora quando ho
conosciuto pietro qui pensavo di essere
sul set di un film fantasy in cui il
protagonista interpreta il ruolo di un
anziano saggio sulla sua montagna in
questo film però onestamente dovrei fare
un appunto ai truccatori perché i
capelli di pietro erano troppo perfetti
per essere realistici dai
comunque a parte gli scherzi ognuno di
questi incontri così apparentemente
lontano dalla normalità e quindi appunto
da film è stato tra i più reali e
autentici che io abbia mai avuto
allora oggi qui vorrei provare a
condividere con voi parte del valore di
questi incontri raccontandovi come sono
finito all'interno di quei film e per
farlo dobbiamo utilizzare la tecnica
cinematografica del flashback
ho scattato questa foto a londra
ovviamente questa foto è il simbolo
della soluzione al mio problema
quale problema
mi sono diplomato al liceo scientifico
di ravenna avete presente quello
studente con un ottimo rendimento
scolastico che sa perfettamente qual è
triennale frequenterà perché poi sa
perfettamente qual è magistrale
frequenterà perché poi sa perfettamente
quale percorso professionale
intraprenderà ecco io ero il contrario
sapevo benissimo cosa non mi piaceva e
faticavo terribilmente a scegliere la
strada giusta per me
il mio blocco derivava dalla paura di
sprecare la risorsa più preziosa che che
ci è concessa il tempo la mia ansia
derivava dell'idea che se avessi scelto
una strada per me automaticamente ne
avrei escluse altre 999 e tra queste e
999 per forza ce ne sarebbe stata almeno
una migliore di quella che io ho scelto
quindi non sceglie
esempio pratico avete presente la sera
quando vogliamo vedere un film ci
troviamo a scorrere il catalogo di un
sito di streaming ci sono tanti film
belli no uno più bello dell'altro
tanto che spesso fatichiamo proprio
sceglierne uno e continuiamo a scorrere
a scorrere che non ci rendiamo conto che
è passata un'ora è tardi per iniziare un
film dall'inizio e andiamo a dormire
senza aver scelto nulla ecco quella era
il mio blocco
c'è un acronimo in inglese che descrive
piuttosto bene questa questa forma di
ansia
che uomo non so se la conoscete sta per
fear of missing out la paura di perdersi
qualcosa di perdere un'occasione una
chance per rimanere tagliati fuori da
una situazione potenzialmente
gratificante per capirci un fumo e
quando la sera stiamo che ne so leggendo
un bel libro sul divano sereni e ci
arriva il self i del nostro migliore
amico in un locale a bianco con altri
amici che si sta divertendo tantissimo e
da lì in poi la nostra lettura sarà
molto meno gratificante
secondo un articolo della fim composto
la formula addirittura descritta come la
paura del nostro tempo e si stima che il
69 per cento dei millennials ne soffra
su base quotidiana e io ero esattamente
uno di quelli ma allora londra in tutta
questa storia cosa c'entra beh londra mi
ha salvato
sono capitato a londra ha quasi per caso
nel primo vero viaggio della mia vita è
appena arrivato sentita subito una
sensazione mai provata prima in tutta la
mia vita certo eravamo il classico
gruppo di ragazzini esaltati dalle mille
luci della città
però oltre a questo accade qualcosa di
più profondo
senti come un fortissimo richiamo verso
quel contesto come se una parte della
mia vita dovesse per forza passare da lì
non sapevo il perché però era ovvio che
quello fosse il posto giusto per me in
quel momento
è come se la mia bussola interiore
avesse finalmente trovato la sua
direzione e si fosse illuminata
io credo che chiunque capiti all'interno
del proprio contesto lo percepisca
immediatamente prima ancora di capire il
perché cosi compresi che dovevo mettere
in pausa la tanto angosciante scelta
universitaria e trasferirmi a londra per
un anno sabbatico non era tanto
importante cosa avrei fatto o come mi
sarei mantenuto in città quanto proprio
ascoltare questo forte richiamo parti
senza un posto dove stare senza un
lavoro con due soldi in tasca
con una pessima credetemi conoscenza
dell'inglese e senza avere già amici
presenti in città se la mia partenza
dall esterno poteva apparire come un po
incosciente in realtà non sono mai stato
così sicuro di qualcosa in tutta la mia
vita e nel giro di un paio di settimane
trovai casa lavoro e mi inserì in un
bellissimo contesto di amicizia e
straniere e da lì il mio viaggio iniziò
e non intendo quel viaggio in senso
fisico nello spostare il proprio corpo
da un punto a un altro
intendo quel viaggio di auto scoperta
che fino a quel momento non aveva mai
avuto la possibilità di compiere
quando frequentiamo a lungo gli stessi
contesti
raramente ci viene data questa
possibilità infatti solo dopo ho capito
perché londra mi attraeva così tanto
perché mi ha dato la possibilità di
azzerare mi di azzerare completamente e
di ricostruirmi da zero in italia
frequentavo gli stessi contesti ormai da
tempo tanti amici ottimi rapporti però
mi rendevo conto che in ognuno di questi
io ero sempre l'immagine che quel
contesto aveva di me
non ero io che frequentava il gruppo in
cui ero considerato quello brillante
simpatico ecco che mi sentivo tale se
invece frequentavo il gruppo in cui era
considerato più timido introverso
ecco che diventavo timido cambiando
contesto cambiava la mia immagine senza
che questa l'avessi mai realmente decisa
io e cambiarla era difficilissimo per
cui io chi era
questo l'ho capito andandomene quando ci
si allontana dalle proprie abitudini si
capisce come la maggior parte dei nostri
pensieri e nelle nostre azioni siano in
realtà figlie di automatismi come
all'interno di un grande ingranaggio
appena arrivato a londra mi sentii
leggero come una tela completamente
bianca su cui ora ero io a poter
dipingere qualcosa
che persona vuoi essere
non me lo ero mai chiesto privano con il
primo amico con cui tu ora ti
presenterai chi tu sarai ai suoi occhi
ora dipende solo da te e lui da qui si
farà un immagine di te e se tu ti
sentirai rispecchiato da questa immagine
ecco la magia la grande sovrapposizione
quando tu sei esattamente ciò che il
contesto che frequenti pensa che tu sia
la sensazione di essere esattamente nel
posto giusto al momento giusto
la provai fortissima eco si affronta i
miei problemi con la foto questa
sensazione forse il contrario netto
della foto la consapevolezza che le
altre 999 scelte fossero tutte peggiori
di questa singola scelta che avevo preso
con questa consapevolezza poi tutto
accade più facilmente anche ascoltarsi
lirici a decifrare con chiarezza cosa
realmente volevo fare quali fossero le
mie passioni raccontare storie
attraverso i video e viaggiare viaggiare
per scoprire prospettive diverse con cui
potermi confrontare con cui potermi
mettere in discussione ed è proprio la
ricerca di queste prospettive diverse
che mi ha portato a conoscere le tre
persone di cui vi ho parlato all'inizio
del discorso
pietro flaminio e rossella ho deciso di
citarmi proprio questi tre persone
perché sono tre eremiti tre persone che
hanno lasciato la società hanno preso la
scelta più antifumo possibile decidendo
spontaneamente di perdersi ogni
possibile occasione che che la vita di
mondo avrebbe potuto offrirgli
pietro non mette piede in una città da
30 anni
flamini invece beve da una borraccia
ricavata dai testicoli di un montone e
rossella invece dorme in una bellissima
e antica casa di pietra con la porta
aperta perché dice che le dà un grande
senso di fiducia nel mondo
e quando a queste persone si chiede
perché
si capisce che la risposta non sta
dentro le parole ma la si percepisce
semplicemente dal loro modo di esistere
la loro scelta non è stata una scelta
razionale come si sceglie un piatto dal
menù di un ristorante
loro mi hanno insegnato che non siamo
realmente noi a scegliere le cose
importanti che accadono nella nostra
vita né quelle belle ne tantomeno quelle
brutte
non siamo noi i registi o gli autori del
nostro film però noi abbiamo un altro
grande potere e vorrei provare qui in
chiusura a spiegarvelo con un esempio
che mi è stato fatto durante un viaggio
e che trovo perfettamente calzante con
questo evento
provate ad immaginare la scena di un
film in cui una madre prepara il pranzo
per il resto della famiglia
ora associate a questa scena una musica
felice e spensierata da spettatori siamo
portati a pensare che la famiglia possa
arrivare da un momento all'altro e tra
poco avranno un bellissimo pranzo tutti
insieme felici
bene ora associate alla stessa identica
scena una musica di tensione di suspense
ora ci aspettiamo che qualcosa possa
succedere da un momento all'altro forse
la madre ha intenzione di avvelenare
qualcuno dei commensali ecco la scena in
sé è ciò che ci accade su cui non
possiamo pretendere di avere totale
controllo
però noi possiamo decidere quale musica
associare a questa scena quale colore
dargli allora e oggi vorrei salutarvi
con un'ultima domanda
quale colonna sonora avete scelto per il
vostro film grazie
[Applauso]